[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
be brave and close your eyes
distract yourself from the world around
you that will still remain unchanged
when you have the strength to open the
game
be brave and close your eyes
give in to the silence that remains
broken only by your breath that quickens
as the beat of your heart rises
be brave and close your eyes marvel as
your thoughts collide within you as you
race to catch up to something out of
your control
[Music]
be brave and close your eyes
let your body lie still while you feel
yourself spiral down a rabbit hole where
you've been before so many times
be brave and close your eyes
feel the adrenaline flow through your
aching lens as you allow yourself to
descend into a reality that is yours and
yours alone
be brave and close your eyes
let yourself be transported to where
your mind needs to be
revel within what the darkness allows
you to see
[Music]
there's so much that we've yet to
understand and even though it feels like
madness this just may be the closest
thing to an alternate reality
as a child i used to believe it so
be brave and close your eyes
where will you go
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello there
as a um little
surprise well somebody's whatever i'm
gonna sing song
just quickly while people come in
attempt to anyway
okay
[Music]
please don't give up on me
i know i'm not
[Music]
please don't give up
[Music]
you're the only person that i've ever
trusted never forcing me to talk until
i'm a justice so i
i just wanted to thank you
[Music]
and i know it can be difficult i know i
can be sad but for some reason you're
still standing by my side
[Music]
so please don't give up on me
i know i'm not perfect
[Music]
i don't want you to
go
[Music]
please
[Music]
i'm so sorry i just don't feel safe
without you and you're gonna feel so
good
i'm just working on myself and i need a
little help to make it through
so thank you for being there for me
even if sometimes i disagree
with things you have to say to me
but your honesty is really
key please don't keep up on me
i know i'm not perfect
but i'm trying
[Music]
please don't give up on me
i'm still just learning
taking baby steps as i go
steps as i go
[Music]
he's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is a song by mxm tune who voiced
the main character of this game so it
makes sense for me to play okay wait let
me actually talk to you now
hello
let's see the chat
hey rick's delight hey and trillian hey
lydia hey bergie
boogieberry
um thanks everyone's liking buttercup
um hey
hey nathan yes yes yes and marshmallows
this would go so well mexico campflat
and marshall's very cute thanks mantas
it's your boy
yazon singing fantastic
oh good glad you liked it glad you liked
it i was just singing it before i
started streaming and i was like you
know what this is a song written by mx17
and she's the one who did the voice
stuff
for the main character so this makes
sense
this makes sense
okay
let's jump straight back into the game
where are we last time
we
um
are looking for that little kid what
would he be to her like um
step nephew would that be basically her
boyfriend no her boy
her brother's
girlfriend's kid has gone to a mine like
an abandoned mine shaft
or some sort of cave system pretty sure
it's mine shaft and he is lost
and we're trying to find him and that
that is what we're going to do now so
let's hop right in and see if we can
find
this little kid who went off in the
mines which uh
probably shouldn't have done that
probably not the best idea really
and back to the lovely music as well
which is always very nice
as always let me know if i'm too loud
the game's too quiet blah blah anything
like that
hello martial
hey sonny
[Music]
fergie unrelated but can i ask about
your tattoo on your huge muscular
sir sure let me um
i'll do it after the cut scene
[Music]
oh thanks man
ethan
ethan
this is where we left off
come on pick up pick up
alex
this way i guess we don't need to watch
this cause we didn't see it last time
basically we just all walk in together
and then he's like let's spit it off i
don't think i can actually skip this
wow
been a while since i was up here
let's ask how worried we should be
should i be
i don't know
freaking out right now
in my experience freaking out is almost
never advisable
any luck and touch base with the safety
team up at the site they're going to
postpone tonight's blast until we find
them
hey
did they have like a good sort of
explosion charlotte's got to be losing
it right now
she's tough
always has been
come on let's take a look around okay
let's go let's go let's go
uh
this kid
can you imagine the [ __ ] we would have
caught from dad if we'd done anything
like that thanks for following franco
and jen
hey
we're gonna find him
yeah
yeah you're right
hey thanks again for your help
could have been a lot worse if you
hadn't kept me in the loop
of course
i'm gonna go take a look around let me
know if you spot any sign of ethan
sure yes yes let's go
i can
do that
how is ethan planning to get into the
sorry
mine i don't want to play with my
controller
um okay so
uh my
tattoo first of all by a guy called mike
stout in brighton very very good artist
he has some really like interesting um
designs as well and he'll he'll do
things handmade for you it's basically
just um a circle of like mountains and
trees i told him i just wanted like
solitary nature and it's really nice um
but let's continue with this
that's mike spout uh he's on he's on
instagram
very cool guy very nice guy
nope
nope
nope
nope
super nope
positive attitude
will we though
[Music]
violations will be prosecuted
i'm sure if they explain the situation
it will be fine
cool
a murder bar
[Music]
this mine could be one there
maybe julie mcnamara doesn't need your
approval
julie mcnamara is a [ __ ] stank
[Music]
they were gonna set off charges tonight
thank god gabe got a hold of them
blasting those here this morning sirens
will be sounded priceless so i guess
they're just like blowing this whole
place up because they don't need it
anymore
but then he's gone here just being like
this would be a cool place for an
adventure
[Music]
oh my god what the hell i thought that
was just a presence back there
how is the rubber zombie the least
creepy thing out here i think it's
creepy
[Music]
the real monster here is underage
drinking
you don't realize until you're up close
but mining equipment is super murdery
hey bro
want to get wasted at the old mine
be cool be cool
[Laughter]
my joyride and this will have to wait
until after we found ethan
okay it's pretty beaten up i wonder what
happened to it
[Music]
i thought we were gonna put it on so we
could be a little more protected
probably not as fun to ride in as they
look
[Music]
imagine being trapped down there
or actually
alex warned me i could have stopped this
such a [ __ ] fuck-up gabe cares about
ethan so much
we have to find him
come on ryan
everyone is depending on you ryan won't
let his fear get in the way
i'm glad he's here
so we've gotten used to using her little
power now but i'm kind of thinking
when does this develop into a mechanic
like
you know like how in the first life is
strange you had the whole like time
shooky thing
will she in the future be able to
manipulate emotions or something
on that wow
once ethan's safe i'll raise one too
hello indie jack
oh am i quiet okay
one sec
let me sort out this
i'll turn the game down a little bit
then thanks for letting me know
uh let me know how that sounds i've just
turned the game down just a tad
okay so
imagine being
trapped down there
what happened here
massive cave-in
bunch of trapped miners all nearly died
jed led the whole team back to the
surface
god
yeah that's the day foreman jed became
local hero jed
and then typhon closed up this site
basically bought jet the black lantern
huh
oh
his drawings his little comic book
same logo
did ethan base his comic on this place
yeah yeah it makes it makes sense
because in his comic the knight was
trying to find a way into the cave thing
and that's exactly what he's trying to
do so let's have a look
okay
i'll have to find another one
if the wall is an illusion
beautiful city guard
long dead so that must be the zombie
blood
the trail seems to end here unless
okay so it's got to be one of the
shutters that i looked at earlier
okay
nothing obvious
maybe we should
notice anything
no [ __ ]
i'll be damned
the whole story is about ethan's
character breaking into a monster
stronghold deep underground
sounds like the mind of me does it show
where he went
not sure
the comic ends with the monster hunter
climbing a watchtower which shows him
where to go
there
the silo i bet that's the tower that's
where he went
you're a genius yeah great find alex
gabe you want to take a crack on
unlocking that gate i'm on it
we should also be able to get to it
through the processing building
if we can find a way in
let's take a look then
okay
ethan based his comic on this place
maybe i should compare his drawings with
other stuff in the area
thank you for following at server
severance
[Music]
i need to find something like that dead
guy yeah the zombie the dead guy so if
the zombie is here
then
[Music]
then the campsite is in front of him and
yeah blood is right
if ethan really followed the path in his
comic
finding him just became a lot more
doable
is his shirtless
halloween party 2k18 yeah
okay so
oh maybe he saw the shadow of the tree
there's a shadow of something i have no
idea but maybe he thought that was like
[Music]
wait so
did ethan
oh man
yeah
[Music]
think there's like a
side door back there
i don't know
i guess there might be give me a hand
you figure that out from a comic book
you can learn many things from comic
books
[Applause]
i'm going to try to get the lights on
you try to figure out where ethan went
sorry to hear your ill wake to light
i feel better soon don't know why that
paused
[Music]
ethan must have come through here
how did he get out
have i got some good news for you
[ __ ]
still getting legalized everywhere now
especially in america i kind of want to
push all the buttons
also
kind of scared to push any of the
buttons
that's wonderful
let's hope omens aren't really a thing
[Music]
nope
thaner doesn't battle any bed bugs ugh
worse than sleeping on the ground
want to go back the other way and see
what we
missed
so much stuff just left behind
[Music]
i hope alex is right about this comic
thing we're burning minutes here i hope
so too
[Music]
this thing has seen better days
that was worth a shot i guess
ethan must have passed through some
other way
let me see what i can figure out
okay so let's get back
if ethan didn't get out through the door
how did he get out
let's have a look at the comic
oh he climbed like a weird
cloud serpent that was it
the corpse of a cloud serpent it must
have crashed through the ceiling
[Music]
yes he got on the cloud seven so
i guess that is the cloud serpent he got
on there
[Music]
i don't know
does anyone know if uh marijuana is
still illegal than in england because
i'm just reading braggy you're saying
that
most of america
has at least decriminalized it all maybe
it's twinkies
those never go bad right
[Music]
wasn't in the comic
it's not in the comic
[Music]
it's gonna be here
ethan must have gone upstairs
pretty sure ethan climbed these stairs
[Music]
[Applause]
class b
i was a little so strange
wasn't in the comic it was not any comic
we passed caution like an hour ago
so from here he jumped on the snake
thing so it's down there
surely
not in the comic
oh okay that's that makes a bit more
sense than vixen like if it is that i
don't know
the silo
we're getting close
[Music]
here it is reminds me of the snake thing
in ethan's comic
read its mind
[Music]
he has been doing some risky stuff
[Music]
yeah oh gosh
[Music]
ethan made the jump from here to the
conveyor belt
i think i'll find another way through
looks like ethan climbed the conveyor
belt out to the silo
heads up
please have big burning muscles
[Music]
you figured out the door
yeah turns out you got to open it who
knew
linda yeah rick's alike feels the same
way what at least i don't think he liked
chloe i
watched a video about chloe and how
she's like the representation of a toxic
friend
and it's like romanticized in the game i
was like you know what
i see it and i totally fell for it
i think we've all i don't know maybe not
all of us but i think a lot of us have
had
people like that in our lives where
we've like formed attachments to them
and it's not the healthiest
so it's very relatable at least
yeah chloe was very selfish i mean she
had been through a lot as well
but
yeah
just some questionable things
what took you so long
you never forget how to break a lock
it's like riding a bike why can't we
just go with you then
where to next alex
comic detective comics detective alex
okay so up there then
somehow
oh there this this way
she knows
[Music]
senor looks out from the watchtower and
spots the secret entrance to the
stronghold
if we can just
there
that's where he's heading
that's by the ravine [ __ ]
let's go
[Music]
i don't even really know what they were
pointing at
it looks like just a big rock to me
did you see an entrance i definitely
didn't see an entrance
i'll believe them i'll trust
we close
think so
ethan
ethan
ethan
a kid out here on his own that's not a
good thing
oh the giant purple light there
oh wait is that his aura though as she
can see
yes
ethan
alex i'm scared
we can see that
ethan i'm coming for you buddy
hold on
here
ethan
you okay
don't worry we're going to get you out
of here
just hang on oh my gosh
surely the the light is
[Music]
his fear is so strong
if i get near it oh i see that's why she
doesn't want him it's not good
we're too heavy
[ __ ]
what about me
alex
are you sure
remember how i taught you how to anchor
a belay
awesome
show me
you okay
uh
no
i'm just gonna be honest honestly
no
that feeling makes sense
do me a favor though
see if you can breathe oh he's so nice
everybody mean about calling him a nerd
because he's a bad musician i'm sorry
dude
alex can you make eye contact with me
not very good at that
i'm going to tie this rope around your
waist
the other end is tied around your
brother
he'll use that stump as a fulcrum
to feed rope your direction
follow
so far
awesome
you're doing super good
remember is steady
steady's fast
piece cake
okay
piece of cake
is this is this a quick time event or
something oh i hope not
i don't think they probably will be this
is like strange everything's chill
you got this alex
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not going back without you
you're stuck with me until we're both
safe
thank you
come real close just a little further
hey ethan
i'm here to help okay no
get away
[Music]
[ __ ]
it's too much
i have to get him to chill out
talk about the comment tell my comments
ethan i need you to calm down
can you breathe for me
i should never have come out here
i was so stupid okay hey
hey focus
talk to me
you want to tell me how you got out here
i was trying to cross to the other side
log
fell that's fine
that's okay
let's talk about what comes next
i've got really good balance no
game's on gabe's got us
we're not gonna fall he's got the other
end of the rope no
i can't move if i move you're not gonna
fall buddy
it doesn't matter
[Music]
he's not making any sense i need him to
calm down
we can't stay here ethan we have to see
me
if i move it'll see me what's gonna see
you
i don't understand no i don't he's right
tell me i don't
i can't help him if i don't understand
what he's afraid of
oh okay so she sees the only way to
understand is to feel what he's feeling
oh
[ __ ] i can't believe this is happening
let's do it i can do this
i can do this
oh thanks babe
[Music]
i bet her brother's happy at the end of
the line going like what just happened
oh wait no because he knows we told him
oh my god
what's happening
it's like i'm seeing the world through
his eyes
i'm not just feeling what ethan feels
i'm seeing the world like he sees it
that's pretty cool
we haven't done this yet
i brought all this stuff
none of
[Music]
this is
okay
he's not afraid of the fall
he's afraid
oh [ __ ]
can't let it see me
can't let it see me
it can't be real
oh but it looks pretty [ __ ] real
hey
hey i see it too ethan
the monster
i see it too
and i'm just as scared as you are
but ethan
we're safe
you know why
can't see us
it can't see me
bangle of vanishing
just like knight warden
i thought that was just a story
hell some stories are true
like monsters
so
you're gonna
hold my hand all right
as long as you're touching me you're
safe
oh this is cute
don't look down okay
we'll be done before you know it
surely with both of their weight
wouldn't both of them mean for one of
the guys
maybe not i don't know
i headed back
keep tight on the belay game
not over yet
oh god
okay
one step at a time that monster is so
cool though
let's do this
alex
yeah buddy
i'm still really scared that's okay
me too yeah
me too
but we can do this
one step at a time
okay
am i falling to the right no to the left
i don't know do you think the log will
break there's nothing i can do
don't worry
i got all the way across before remember
it could still break
yeah maybe that wasn't the best thing to
say
sorry about that
i don't know
you're on rope it's all good don't worry
about it
can we do this
can we do it
come on
they're good man tight grip we're close
now
okay we're good we're good wake up lenny
is scared don't mind we're all good
that's it
come
on i got you
all right we got his backpack
[Music]
you have to test me
oh i didn't know we're in silent hill
okay so i guess that's the um they're
gonna blow it's gonna
blow okay
oh
no he can't be dead
what
[Music]
what
this
what does that happen at the end of
every first episode there's no [ __ ]
no [ __ ]
what
all right we're gonna have to at least
start the second one then because that
is
ball
no way right alex told gabe about
ethan's plans 53 did that oh
it's basically 50 50 on that um
that was about whether you told your
brother
if um the
uh
if the kid was going into the mines or
not
told why the truth about the fight
yes why would you not yeah she deserves
to know
telling gabe i can't no gabe can't be
dead i just don't we we're gonna play
and find out
he can't be dead
like what
we just got here
alex hud gabe on the bridge yeah of
course why would you not alex encouraged
riley to be honest in an interview
yes honest honest
put the sunglasses on them gnome yeah
enjoyed the song in the record store
yeah
alex told ryan that gabe was a badass
yeah
alex rocked out with gabe and the
broomer guitar all this is very obvious
stuff alex wasn't sure how she felt
about haven
fair
alex told judge she'd never been a
server yeah you've got to be you've got
to be honest i think especially when it
comes to a job i'm not going to lie but
like i'm the best person ever um alex
told gabe she loves the guitar
of course why would you not um jeff was
impressed with alex's performance as a
server job was not impressive oh judd
figured out alex had never been a seven
before steph lost to alex in the jukebox
game
riley
broke up with mac yes yes yes
ducky was reunited with his favorite
whiskey
okay let's do the next chapter because i
cannot leave it there that's not fair
i can't believe that
oh gosh
well the bottom of the cliff is a ravine
so you could have just landed in water
that's true jan
but also
like loads of
boulders went over after i'm not big on
speeches
i've always believed that the role of
the bartender
is to shut up and listen
and by that measure
gabe was the worst bartender i've ever
known
yeah he's not alive
i never
issued a speeding ticket
to someone on a bicycle before
until he came along
he cared
so much
about my admissions essay
even though he probably couldn't spell
admissions
or essay
he booked my van to play the lantern
all the way from seattle
to pretty much right where i'm standing
i can recall 14
specific instances
where gabe said something that made me
laugh
[Music]
the first was two years ago
so
long story short
instead of a ticket
i ended up buying him a beer
gabe stood like
three feet away
grinning like doofus at us
i'm sure there were more people
but i only remember him
and then he said i know
that's why the k is silent
[Laughter]
then the fifth time
he cared about everyone
[Music]
he was the kind of guy
you wanted to be around
he was a world-class bullshitter
he was my
best friend
[Music]
all i want to say about gabe is
he came into this bar as a stranger
but he left at his family
i cannot i just still
guess that's that then
what happened to gabe
was a senseless tragic accident
and i just wish that it wasn't an
accident
son now is not the time gabe called the
mine
i gave him my sat phone to be sure he
could get through
they [ __ ] up
does that guy work at the mine no he did
this on purpose
no
now gabe's dead
that was my shift
if anyone had called it would have gone
through me
nobody called
you're lying
cool
in front of gabe's own [ __ ] sister
alex heard the whole thing
ah
i don't want to get into this eye
can i just stay quiet
um
i mean i did
i don't know don't lie
i was there when gabe made the call oh
i hate confrontation even in video games
i'd like to hear what you have to say
about that mac
i'm not saying anything wait why are we
that one he called i didn't get a call
oh god try your own conclusions
all right folks
this is an ongoing investigation how
about it we review the sequence of
events
when i saw you at the record store you
seem pretty eager to find games
remember why
i just don't like him another fight with
riley maybe no i don't have to take this
just saying
pretty wild that you come stumbling out
of gabe's apartment with your face all
[ __ ] up right in just a couple hours
later you just so happened to have
missed the call that would have saved
his life i told you there was no call to
miss
and maybe the call got dropped
or [ __ ] i mean it's not like it's like
gabe was mr reliable all the time watch
your mouth mac right that's enough
now i'm just as eager as you to
understand all this son but there was a
time oh [ __ ] dad
this little weasel's calling gabe a liar
at his own [ __ ] weight oh i am just
telling you mac i swear if you say there
was no call one more [ __ ] time stop
it
stop it now yeah guys
this is not the time
or place
we're all here for gabe
okay ryan
sure i'm
i'm sorry
it's not i mean
whatever happened i'm just trying you
can't undo it
i'm not the one who killed him
oh god they're not saying that
aren't you though
what what the [ __ ] did you just say ryan
back off oh i'm just saying i thought i
heard that you were the one you shut the
hell up no
no go ahead you got something to say mac
let's [ __ ] hear it guys don't make me
interview all right
fine
as long as we're tossing around
accusations way i hear it you're the guy
who cut the rope
god
just didn't like that that wasn't easy
everyone helped
they do a good very good job of making
the players realize as well
yeah i agree chris i kind of like that
in these types of games
you just gotta alex
just
choose an option and go with it
hey
[ __ ] those guys
yeah
are you okay
ah
hell name
god no
i'm a [ __ ] wreck
it's not your job to keep it together
thanks
do you
um
it's messy
but
do you want to come in
sure
so it was pointed out to me
staff is um
the girl that you played d and d with in
the first game i'm pretty sure it was d
you played some sort of tabletop game
and uh yeah
this is hair
that's pretty cool
you play guitar
sort of
it was a gift
from gabe
cool
oh that's awkward maybe i shouldn't have
said that
gabe would try to pop wheelies outside
the record store to make me laugh
never worked
till he wiped out
that was hilarious
hmm
gabe really wanted to do the larp for
ethan
but by the end of it
he was more jazzed about it than anybody
wish i could have seen it
we took this a year ago
we
what
what no way
i can't
what
you actually kept it
what a dick
sorry
i just need a minute
yeah
uh no problem
calm down alex
you're fine
you're fine
whatever that bottle made her think of
it really messed her up
i wonder if i could help her the same
way i helped ethan
i need to feel her sadness to figure out
how to help her
i can see everyone in the chat talking
about whether ryan is guilty or not i
see your points they are all very valid
um
because ryan did cut the rope but then
i guess ryan did that instinctively
because
it
quite possibly would have been both of
them dead instead of just one
ah
because the rope was keeping her
in harm's way basically but i don't know
i mean he obviously has natural
survival instincts because he's out in
the forest all the time with his birdie
stuff
um but he definitely definitely would
feel some sort of guilt i mean he has to
surely
this is a tough one isn't it
okay uh
let's feel
[Music]
[Music]
so now
now i can find out what's really going
on with staff have a look at everything
from steph's point of view that's cool
what are they called again don't [ __ ] on
my yard they're amazing their guitarist
has one arm badass
dude give it up i already booked a bus
ticket wait wait hear me out one more
game if i win you have to stay
if you win i'll cover the ticket you
just lost 50 bucks
so what's she gonna move out of the
town
here's to your new job at the station
oh didn't i tell you
i'm not taking it
i moved to denver next week you
what
wait so was she supposed it was that
before she was supposed to move
is she still moving i don't know i guess
we'll find out
damn it [ __ ] overpowered blue meteor
oh
is your controller broken too
we're playing until i win then i'll be
crashing here tonight the baby game
together
that's cute
ladies and gentlemen
presenting
your new foosball champion gabe chen oh
you're the worst
i can't believe i have to stay in this
stupid town okay i think we both know
you could have beat me if you really
wanted to so you're welcome [ __ ]
i think i know enough to help her now
still can't believe he's gone
yeah
he's the whole reason i'm still
i'm sorry alex
don't mind me
yeah cause i mean it's hard for alex
cause she just got a brother back and
now he's gone but she didn't know him
like like everyone else did
but i guess they also didn't know him
like she didn't
um
so let's talk about
the
foosball
[Music]
how about a quick match
did gabe tell you we played
i just had a hunch
yeah well you're right
i don't really think it's a great time
yeah i didn't really mean to ask you for
a game that's a bit weird sorry about
that
fine
oh okay okay okay okay
taking out her um
competitive first of five points
if you say so
asdf okay
so how often did you engage play
it was one of our favorite games
you must be pretty good then
mm-hmm
wait if i'm to get an f
you were in a band right
yeah
would you play
drums i let her win
i should probably just let her win how
uh how long did you play with them
too long
gotcha
i'll let her win so hopefully she gets
happy
but i'm not gonna make it seem like i'm
letting her win obviously i need to
you know try a little bit
okay you win this time
go on
go on
come on i'm not doing anything please
what how i wasn't doing anything
please win
we're both on like one point now sorry i
really don't know don't don't do this
please
oh no go
damn it
i'm so sorry i tried to win that's game
yep
big shocker
oh hey at least you played your best
i mean that obviously wasn't my best no
i get it
i mean this is a tough game
requires skill
timing
and the will to be a champion
oh
is that how it is
wait
hold on
the crowd is really picking up on my
energy
we love you
alex ah stress sucks
okay i don't know i want to rematch all
this in this situation that they're
so weird i guess she's just replacing
her brother right now
i'm actually trying this time so you
better focus
i am focusing okay let's let her win
good i wouldn't want you to get
distracted or anything
certainly not
[Music]
greatest northwest band of all time go
are you trying to distract me
of course not
slater kenny if you're wondering
okay
let's let her win that one
i'm very
strategic i came into the bloody way
strategic
okay
oh yes
let's do one more
i game know oh come on you know gabe
would never let a tie stand
well then it's settled
okay
this is it for all the marbles so many
marvels
definitely the kind of game you want to
focus on no matter what happens
totally
i was actually trying then
hey so are you into girls or what
oh uh
i'll date anybody assuming they're my
type
what's your type
i'll let you know when i meet them
this is what
what what what is she just stuck
i knew it
how old are you exactly old enough to
know better
ah this is actually hard to win against
her
come on
let me get a couple more points
i haven't played this game in such a
long time
okay let her win this one
oh [ __ ] finally
rush house of chen crumbles at last
good game
gg thank you
you're a much better loser than gabe
that's no fun
sorry to spoil the victory
much better
it's kind of crazy that you knew exactly
what would cheer me up
don't give me too much credit
i'm the one who really needed it
it feels like there's going to be so
he's clearly lying right
yeah i need to learn more
i'm not sure what max deal is
his story doesn't add up yeah
i do know that i need to find out
exactly what happened that night
for myself
and for gabe
i've got your back
no matter what
thank you
that means a lot
i should head back to work
cool
bye
bye
she love interest
i kind of want her to be a love interest
that i should fit too
i know gabe made that call
but did mac really let the blast go off
just to get back at him
i think we have chemistry
i never got to see bartender gabe in
action
but he left some pretty big shoes to
fill
i still don't know what's up those
stairs maybe we can go up them now
see
i can be a person
[Music]
oh the game will remember that that was
very important oh
i can go upstairs
should we do
should we clean up this place is a tip
do you do the dishes
[Music]
it's a start
[Music]
not much to toast at the moment
feels like a million years since that
day with gabe
it hasn't even been a week
i yeah
it all happened so bloody fast and he he
was totally cool with the power stuff
it's really sad
okay so
he it's not like he died last night then
i guess he died um clean home clean mine
yeah he would have done it with you that
happened literally the first night that
she was there isn't it
one of the happiest memories i have
thanks
gabe at least i got to have a few good
moments
you served him well
i wonder how she's really holding up
yeah i'm wondering that like with her
son as well
i wonder how her son's doing i hope he
doesn't kind of like you know blame
himself or anything like that
thanks for sticking around
oh yeah let's get dressed
[Music]
is that like a throwback to the second
game i like this cat one it's so cute
okay let's keep this
all right let's go upstairs and see
what's up here
hey the taco guy i'm i'm pretty sure i
remember you didn't you play perfection
and then i put like put you in a video
i'm so sorry if i just got like
completely wrong
i remember you being funny
compliment uh wow
oh
so this is where we were
sat with gabe when we told him about our
power
this is really pretty [ __ ]
this just makes me want to like
move
to nature
which unfortunately is not where any of
the jobs are but i'm really hoping that
more jobs are going to be remote working
so that we can just
get up and move wherever we want instead
of having to live around these super
congested cities that are really high
highly priced
i'm just
unable to have a good quality of life
just
it just doesn't make sense to me
yeah would be nice anyway the answer my
friend
is blowing in the wind
why look up at the sky
when you could look at a sculpture
instead
i'll toss those soon i swear oh she
doesn't want to throw his
ah that makes sense
no birds today
gabe really loved this place gabe was
such a dad
ugh
imagine having
a imagine having a rooftop place this
thing's been up here a while with this
view isn't that steph's old band
drugstore makeup
cute
you could stay here too
i wouldn't try to stop you
yeah good
i'll be the only trans person in a town
with a population of like four
that sounds like a blast for me thanks
for not trying to stop me
i'm sorry izzy
it's not you
and it's not the band
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
but i need to try this
it's just
time for something new
i knew it
i knew this would happen eventually
[ __ ]
see you around stuff
okay so her band did not take that well
when she decided to stay here
so she really did just stay here for
gabe
i bet gabe could even make golf fun
this place is super
freaking nice okay
let's go and sit in the chair and
probably
have a little song play for us because
that's what usually happens
[Music]
i thought this was going to be the one
finally
despite all the disappointments
i really let myself believe
i believed you
completely
i let myself hope
really hope
for the first time in years
even after i freaked out in front of you
and hit you
you didn't push me away
he sat right there
and told me that i wasn't broken
that i was special
and i belonged
then you died
then i don't know what to believe now
except you're gone again
and i'm still here
alone
[Music]
this
as a florida resident can confirm the
speed bump in front of our public globe
grocery store is the state's tallest
[Music]
yeah i mean i know some of you know that
i recently came out from scotland but
geez i had some views just like this and
the lake district
so many [ __ ] nice places
i'd love to go to
like northern canada as well i've been
to like the south carolina
[Music]
all right
time to go
[ __ ] music
i'm having a small event for your
brother tomorrow at nine i'd love for
you
i'd love to have you there no pressure
okay take all the time i need jed
alex let me know if you need any
groceries i'll cover the cast yet
thanks chad
i'm so sorry
apartment's yours for as long as you
need you know where to find me
everything comes out now what a cutie
can i clean this up no okay
oh it's so sweet that they've just like
accepted her as well
so i know he's gone but at least she's
got like a little a little family in in
the town at least
oh gosh
well at least there's some donuts left
mum
oh hey kid you don't have to do that
too late
i wanted to apologize
for all of us
we're all grieving but that's no excuse
it was your brother's wake and you both
deserve better than listening to a bunch
of fools squabble
i appreciate it
that was pretty rough
although it's hard to imagine a good
version of your dead brother's wake
no there's no good version
just all of us trying to get through it
together the best we can
wasn't the first wake held in this old
building
i doubt it'll be the last
anyway if there's anything i can do just
let me know
i need to talk to mac
i know he's lying i just don't know why
any idea where i can find him
well he helps out eleanor at the flower
shop that'd be the place to start
thanks
oh so i guess i'm back together then i
feel like i should warn you though
you might not get the kind of closure
you're looking for
if you get any at all just
don't pin all your hopes on mac loudon
i get it
thanks for looking out for me but
what else am i supposed to do
i wish i had an answer for you
but
if you get a chance before you go all
dirty harry
swing by the dispensary charlotte wants
to see you
and one more thing
i've been meaning to give you this for
the last few days
but i
didn't want to disturb you up there
it'll get you through that door
and the one upstairs
the one upstairs
this is your home now
for as long as you'd like
oh
oh that's so sweet
what about rent
what about rent
i don't want to be a freeloader
don't worry about that for right now
we'll work out a way for you to earn
your keep when the time comes
thank you
give him hell
i
i have no idea what to even say to him
alex i'm so sorry i should have saved
him i don't know what to say
and then she didn't reply
hey that was terrible you shouldn't have
to see that that was at the week
i
know you're going through a lot but can
we talk i know it's asking a lot but i
really need to talk to you
oh gosh ryan just
give her some like space
okay let's have a look at everyone
gabe
why
why the game do this so early this is so
annoying
um
i'm holding a small service
make sure to be down soon glad to hear
it okay
riley
alex i'm so sorry please let me know if
there's anything i can do that's really
sweet stuff
um
i'm so sorry i love gabe i can only
imagine what you're going through please
call me if you need anything that's
sweet ducky
didn't wait
didn't say anything
did you not say anything i thought it
was a new text nope
charla
alex i'm so sorry you don't have to
respond i just want to tell you thanks
for saving ethan's life i don't know
what i would do if i lost him thank you
i'm so sorry thank you so much i'll
bless her
oh bless
and then my
vlog gabe was the most caring person
i've ever met he never stopped looking
for ways to make life better
[Music]
he's the kind of person you meet once in
a lifetime
we're having a send off for gabe chen
and the lantern on wednesday
ah
silverton will be operating on regular
hours
um so i'm just looking in here for
anything
to
show us that the explosion was um
suspicious but i can't really see
anything
hmm
i feel sick
we here at typhon mining we're shocked
and saddened to hear about gabe chen's
death such loss of life is always tragic
and affects many in our community
oh and they have disabled replies as
well
uh we would like to take this time to
assure the community that typhoon
remains committed as always to follow
instructor safety practices your
community is our community
blah blah blah blah
is it now is it
okay
why did you mean to get my phone just i
just looked at my phone
i've written stuff about s staff sorrow
seth sadness was born out of love it
wasn't empty there was a dimension to it
a form and volume of loss that i could
step inside and then i met a game who
felt much like my own only more so an
instigator a listener a product a
cheerleader as shits tara
a brother it wasn't long but it was
enough to know exactly what stephanie
did the best piece of my brother i could
conjure for her from thin air for just a
moment so we played foosball and for
once steph got to win it was a dumb and
goofy and over in a flash but
in its wake the sadness was lifted and
gabe didn't seem quite as good as he was
before
first ether and now steph i think i'm
finally starting to understand this
thing
that's good
no one could blame me for wanting to
drink all my sorrows away
let's put a song on
what do we want
itchy thiosis
let's just put this on
jet definitely has a decorating style
i'd call it steakhouse chic
i know i'm supposed to be leaving but
i'm just going to look around for us
gabe would have appreciated having beer
at his wake
i should put something here it's the
least i can do
what would you put
[Music]
have i got anything i hope ducky didn't
finish this by himself
they must have been close
poor ethan
i wish we'd had more time
[Music]
gabe jen
smooth criminal
oh that's the ticket that he was
supposed to give him
courtesy of haven's favorite dj i bet
i don't have anything to put that do i
add something to the memory table
oh continue how do i leave how do i need
this
maybe i can find something upstairs to
put on the memory table okay that's a
good idea
ducky everyone else what
[Music]
why do i feel like this is a challenge
i love hot sauce
would have been fun to let gabe kick my
ass at pool
okay let's find some things fit on the
table then
[Music]
wonder what i can find up here to add to
gabe's memory table
i mean
that award would have been quite a good
one he'd just stick his snowboard on
there or something
the album
oh you can't take that one oh fair okay
so i guess it's just
the album or the ep or whatever
let's take that
there's nothing else i can take out here
this is perfect for the memory table
okay let's go back down
hot ones reference
oh yeah i do like spicy food i
definitely do
whenever you get spicy food in england
as well it's always like is it going to
be english or is it going to be like
it's going to be english is it going to
be spicy and i don't have something to
add
because it's it's always just i can
hardly taste it but there's a proper
mexican place i go to near mine
and he makes proper like mexican tacos
he's great
um and every time he's like do you want
hot sauce i'm like yeah and he's like
are you sure though because it's really
really hot it's obviously really hot and
it gives you the tiniest bits all you
need because it's actually really hot
but it's still a place it still tastes
really great
okay that's good
did that
hopefully things around here can settle
down again
yeah
that'd be good
on here rm and tb
i wonder who they were
ah thanks chris
there are more people that live here
that we don't know okay jed said i might
find mac in the flower shop
but i have time to swing by the
dispensary if i want
see what shall i say
uh
charlotte she needs our advice okay
oh wait and uh
text us
nothing big i'll tell you when you get
here
uh do you have a sec to swing by the
store
okay so steph wants us to go there as
well
okey dokey den
okay
this is probably the most haven thing
i've seen yet
it's literally right outside your door
have you not seen it tragically now
isn't the time to check out the rest of
haven
you've been here for like a week and you
still haven't checked it out yet i guess
you have been
going through a lot of stuff i'm not
going to judge you
on one hand there's the open road and
the freedom to run away from my problems
on the other helmet hair
was it on the news
i wonder how many fish ducky's caught in
this thing
no one's been fired
yet
that's nice
do i even want to stay here without gabe
in this state i've never been to before
this town i've been in for less than a
week
[Music]
not that i know where else i'd even go
back to the nothing waiting for me in
portland
[Music]
[ __ ]
i have no idea what comes next
but i'm not leaving here without answers
about gabe
at least i know that
i wonder if i am dreaming
everything feels so strange now
under this old town sky
[Music]
i
[Music]
okay
[Music]
the park looks fun to explore hello lady
if not for the paddling kayaking would
be super relaxing
sorry about leveling all your mountains
here's a bench
i haven't been a bartender long
but i'm pretty sure these are supposed
to stay in the bar
oh hello
hello
will you be my friend i'm new here my
brother just died
okay bye
you're writing a novel
since when
i just started
i have no idea what i'm doing
what if i die tomorrow
just like that guy
what have i done with my life i don't
have any easy answers for that these are
the thoughts that i have all this summer
what's the rush
i guess i
no
you're right
you're right
this is cool
in a wicker man sort of way
i don't think this whole town is a pagan
cult but i can't rule it out either
it's ethan jeez
okay let's get down here
[Music]
oh he's angry he's doing good
everyone needs to stop
telling me it's okay it's not [ __ ]
losing gabe's been hard enough for a
supposed grown-up like me
but for ethan
hey buddy
hey alex
do you
want to talk about it
i'm fine
okay
all right like what are you doing
definitely not fine
okay
i wish i could do something should i try
and talk to him again
everyone needs to stop
telling me it's okay it's
i'm here for you
whenever you need me
okay yeah that's good let's leave it at
that hey newspaper guy how are you doing
ah this is awful
he was so young he must be reading about
gabe
at this point well that's cool i
wouldn't be surprised if the spring
festival ends with a ritual sacrifice a
bagel
i realized the other day
that the the castle
that um um
um um king arthur
uh was born and grew up in well wasn't
born there but grew up in there
and that merlin
um
lived in a cave underneath of
is literally
is it called like tintagel or something
it's literally like an hour away from my
home city so i'm definitely i don't know
i feel like there's a lesson here about
love leaving a mark on the world and i'm
not in a [ __ ] mood there is a carving
of merlin on the outside on a stone on
the outside of the cave
i mean obviously an artist did it but
super cool where are you hiding my
feathered friend
please
i need you is she looking for
a bird oh sorry
you're fine cool binoculars
you bird watching
yeah i'm trying to win a contest
oh
good luck
thanks
oh sorry
you're fine
what if i'm secretly a total prodigy at
disc golf but never had the chance to
find out probably for the best honestly
there's so much to look at
at least back then the only people dying
in mining accidents were miners
do you see him over by the water
there's literally nothing i can do for
ethan
i feel so useless i've been there
to say
yeah we weren't literally just there
so where should we go now
that might be our feathered friend
what
oh my gosh i wonder if this is the bird
that woman is looking for
maybe i should let my binocular friend
know
make some friends
hello i see a bird
there's a huge bird over by the wall
seriously
that might be my hawk thank you
you're very welcome are you not gonna go
why aren't you going oh okay
goodbye
uh that is a bench but i'm sure one day
you will find a way around it
that's brilliant she's just given out
was too young
just
too young
hey pike
hey
um how you holding up
i guess i've been better
yeah right
dumb question that's all right hey
i want you to know i meant what i said
back there gabe was something else
he could bring a smile to my face even
on the worst days
yeah
that's what everyone's been saying
and uh
when you're ready
i still need to get your statement for
the investigation
i'll be ready soon
i think i'll be ready soon
yeah
yeah
no rush
everyone's so nice here
insert epiphany about new beginnings
here
then
that's like the weeds in brighton all
the weeds and it's locations
and word around the water cooler is the
mining company
is about to expand both customers here
are a lot nicer than in denver never
been to denver
but i guarantee they're nice here
i'm a little spooked if typhoon goes
under i'd lose all my business
it's very unlikely that anything with
typhon will chain
nice to know
hipsters can survive at this altitude
wind chimes
wind chimes
the original jam band
oh books over there oh there's mine here
it's [ __ ]
we have a right to know what's happening
to our job type in eight years of my
life and they can't give me back one
simple answer about my job typhoon
doesn't give a [ __ ] about anyone
yeah because they won't tell us a damn
thing so typhoon might be going under
because i just might be a good time to
check out the dispensary
jed said charlotte wants to talk to me
nothing says festive like three
exclamation points
i might be too close to the issue to
have an unbiased opinion
but [ __ ] this this measure proposes
selling property of no more than 20
acres to type in mining for use in this
open pit mine both the sale profit and
subscribe
basically giving more land to them
after what they've done obviously
want to do something together next week
no
sure i have a pottery class wednesday
night want to join
uh class
uh maybe
could we get dinner first
oh god yeah i usually grab a bite with
katie you should come
might be a good time to check out the
dispensary
man can't you take a hint she's not into
you let it go that's rough
are you sick of me if i tell him i like
him
we'll date
and then we'll break up
and then i'll lose my best friend yes
usually how it goes maybe i could help
them wait hell no what am i thinking
this is none of my business
it's not really
and
if he's there just for one thing like
um
just enjoy being
with someone that might be a good time
to check out the dispensary
jed said charlotte wants to talk to me
sorry about today
one doctor had me try
meditation i always just fell asleep
can i get inside
but i was really looking forward to
climbing teller's peak
why should one accident close all the
trails
what a wasted vacation yes
where steph asked me to pop by the
record store if i had time look no i
want to know what your initial thought
was to that selfish lady i guess i'm not
allowed down here
why is he acting like this acting like
what
maybe i can get her to tell me
hey riley
alex
hey
uh who's she talking about
i think if i ask about mac
she'll get angry or something so i'm
just gonna play it safe and ask about i
don't know you and eleanor seem close
she's taking care of me ever since i was
little
i never really knew my mom but
she's always been there for me
what does she think about you going away
to school
she's thrilled
i think she just wants me to end up
happy
that's nice
that's really sweet
she's the most selfless person i know
she's lucky to have you
thanks
i know you and gabe were close
how are you doing
i miss him
so much
he was like an older brother to me
i'm glad he had you
thank you alex
i think that sounds nicer than i'm glad
you had him
it could come across as like
at least you had him because he's my
brother and i didn't i don't know maybe
you never know with these games that
fight mac had with gabe over your secret
meetings
they were about you applying to college
right
yeah ever since the first time mack lost
his [ __ ] in front of them
gabe and charlotte had tried to get me
to end things with him
and after all this
i can see that they were right
do you think he's telling the truth
about the call
that gabe never made it
no i i
it's not that
i
sorry
i'm really not ready to talk about it
that's okay
no i'm not gonna push her
okay
i gotta run
there's some stuff i need to do i feel
i'd feel bad if i pushed her i probably
would have gotten something but i feel
bad
i don't want to push riley but i need to
know more about mac
how do i get her to open up
yeah
if he's innocent why is he acting like
this
okay so he's doing something
simple but effective
who was this what's this
i know what this means
somewhere
there's a dog i need to pet hell yes
okay we'll find we'll find that dog
what could be back there
let's find out
damn
maybe there's something around here i
can use to get it open
yeah
i've broken into places for less
would that actually work
in real life would that actually work
[Music]
i don't think so i'm not breaking into
someone's house here okay no okay good
ye
and i cannot stress this enough ah
[Music]
why did i come in here
just to look at that wheel and go yeehaw
i did didn't i what
no
i can't believe that okay maybe i'll
come back here later
even after everything
i never had to live on the street
i hope this person's alright
i really feel like i missed something in
there but i really don't know what else
i would do in here
it's nothing to look at
okay
i don't know how to get her to open up
might be a good time to check out the
dispensary
jed said charlotte wants to talk to me
yes yes yes we shall go
oh thanks gabriel that's really cute
with you to say that's not cute very
nice for you to say why don't they cute
all the time i think
i'm glad you enjoy the content
oh sorry
we met briefly you're gabe chen's sister
right
alex yeah
i didn't know him well
but i could tell he had a big heart
i'm so sorry for your loss
she
charlotte alex hey
judd said you wanted to see me
i just
wanted to see how you were doing
oh
i'm staying busy i've been trying to
stay busy mostly
yeah apart from those two days and leave
my room but you know
how about you
i can't even imagine what you're going
through
honestly i'm really trying to keep it
together for ethan
he's hurting
he does seem distant
he practically just lost a father
but he's shutting me out he's never done
that before
not when it mattered
yeah
he's a pretty insightful kid
he knows how much you're hurting even
when you try to hide it from him
instead of trying to be strong
maybe the best thing you can do is show
him that
it's okay to hurt
that's really helpful alex
thank you i just realized that was
underscored like the other option that i
didn't want to do so maybe i do need to
do that i can't get over the feeling
that the one person who could help me
deal with the aftermath of gabe's death
escape
what is this
an affidavit
from typhon
if i sign i'm agreeing not to press
charges
in exchange for a payment
a pick one
that's shady
dicey that's so shady
why would they be offering you money if
they didn't do anything wrong
they say it's an offer of good faith
but you're right
dead because of them
and i'd be letting them off
are you gonna sign it
i don't know
i'm trying to put ethan first but
morally say no but logic says yes
oh god i think it would be a betrayal of
gabe yeah i wouldn't do it
should we choose turn down the offer
everyone i think i think i
want to go for that one
what do you all think
that's why we have to eat the rich
i found your game looking for
psychonauts two content ah
i love that game too i because i did the
first impressions but then i carried it
on carried on playing it offline and
yeah it's so so much fun i
played it all very quickly
it's a very good game
go with what you want to go with if
turn it down [ __ ] those guys
all right nathan
oh
sorry didn't i turn on some sort of
streamlabs thing
i might have some sort of streamlabs
thing on and now it's like telling
people off when they're using foul
language
um i'll have to look into that make sure
it's not you can you can use that foul
language
um
i don't know what's happening i came
late basically our brother's dead who is
also this
lady's boyfriend uh and died by like an
accident but might not really be an
accident done by a mining company and uh
to get out of being sued they are
offering her a bunch of money and she's
asking yeah should i take the money for
my son ethan or should i turn down the
offer because it killed your brother and
my boyfriend so i think we're going to
turn it down
oh thank you so much on the uh congrats
gabriel well gabriel
okay wait we're turning it down
i don't think you should sign it
i'm sorry i know it's hard
but you can't let typhon buy you off
gabe made that call
and i'm gonna prove it
i just
i need some time
thanks oh gosh i'm so sorry everyone i'm
i'm gonna have to look into that and uh
make sure that all the auto mods are
turned off
if they're willing to pay charlotte to
keep quiet
they're definitely hiding something yes
they are
i really appreciate you stopping by
feel free to take a look around if you
want yeah let me give you the cars she's
right
but i could really use that money we
can't give in
no matter how hard it is
i'm always here for you if you need
anything okay so maybe we should go back
to the other girl
probably cost more than my bus ticket
god
put some clothes on
[Music]
it blows my mind that charlotte's been
running the dispensary this whole time
i couldn't even leave the apartment
as you may have heard someone very close
to movies and passed away the last few
days have been very hard on me so we're
doing our best to keep our heads up so
many of you have reached that kind of
words i'll try my best to open this up a
few hours every afternoon but things
will probably be a little sprouted for
the next few weeks bless her yeah it's
gonna be hard
when did you start needing a phd to
smoke pot
uh this is like a new strain and like
it's it's more relaxing stairway to
haven
believe it or not gabe named that one
oh i believe it
and he did it all with one rusty saw and
a bottle of gin
impressive
wonder what it's like to have i do my
drugs out of a glass sculpture type of
money
i could totally paint that
i just don't want to
these are my kind of discounts
a little steep
but can you really put a price on a
kid's dreams
nice contribution gabe
gabriel nice
that must be another one of hers because
she's also an artist she doesn't just
run this shop
the highest education of them
what is she doing
[Music]
in the dominican they're said to house
the spirits of gods
mostly i just like how it looks
it's really cool
there's something you don't see in
portland
i really love charlotte's style
sweet logo
but charlotte designed it herself
[Music]
charlotte's dedication to her art is so
inspiring
and which part of the brain is
responsible for the crazy glowy feelies
these bougie dispensaries are gonna put
all the creepy dudes named gene out of
business
[Music]
man
these things better do the trick
i'm averaging like
three hours a night
pro tip
insomnia doesn't usually come from
nowhere and thc is way better at
treating it when you're also tackling
the underlying cause
[Music]
any idea what's keeping you up
probably his childhood or something
hey what if he had something similar to
what we have
and that's why he was so quick to
believe it
there's nothing quite like a cup of weed
on a cold day
okay
we're done with the weed store
let's go back to that other
woman then and just and say the
underlined thing
what just happened oh so we have this
power where we can like sense other
people's emotions but also now we're
learning to harness it we can also
um sense how people feel about certain
objects if they feel very strongly about
a certain object what's she looking at
still need to check the flower shop for
mac she's like
yeah and i need to go to the record
store
oh should i i just feel bad about um
this but i guess we will do it do you
want to talk about mac
yeah
i get it
it's just
if you didn't do anything wrong
why is he acting like he has something
to hide
he asked me to leave haven with him
what
right after the wake
he wouldn't tell me why
but he just looked so guilty
i told him no
and that we were done
and now
i'm scared
he did something horrible
riley
thank you
for telling me
you deserve the truth
i gotta run
there's some stuff i need to do
okay
whale
we'll talk soon
bye
yeah
whenever you want
i just get a text
oh it's just the
i'm kicking up a new adventure for haven
dm me if you want to get involved what
insanity is coming for us next
a year ago i was ready to ditch this
place to keep moving like i always do a
year ago gabe was the reason i say but
even though it's gone now and i'm
missing like hell i still have reasons
to say thanks for showing me that alex
oh that's cute
okay
um
wait who's this
mac luden has deleted their comment so
mac left a comment and he deleted it
that's shady
is he doing anything else anywhere else
i can't see
shady shady mac trying to skip town is
sketchy as [ __ ]
i bet i could use that to stoke his fear
yeah
uh okay
i love being on hold
yikes
cancel aaa membership okay we're just
going no i said cancel i have to imagine
gabe would be amused to know he made it
in the newspaper
cancel
oh another lady who doesn't know how to
walk cancel
and bench girl
it's that guy's sister
i feel so bad for her steph asked me to
pop by the record store if i had time
i know where is the record store it's
over here somewhere isn't it
steph asked me to swing by she's got to
be around here somewhere
helpful
oh what's up
looks like steph might be working on a
new project
time to pay a visit to an old friend
snap or should i say an old enemy
you don't belong here monster slayer i'm
not leaving till i get answers you won't
be living at all
where is the sky sword fine i'll tell
you
the sword was now seen the city of
carnos carneros but it's infested with
where spiders all who quest for that
sword lose something dear to them but i
am destined
to save the round with the sky sword
good thing you won't be crusty alone
owen
is he making new comics because that's
good hopefully he's
working out his emotions through art
which is always good
chrissy looks sweet it would definitely
be wrong to claim someone else's lost
dog
right
yes
gabe was hoping i'd get back into
playing
maybe i will
private mining interests will put their
bottom lines before your family's health
you don't say
um
val
i just want to be friends
evil kitty she does not like hugs
ninth warden's cool but not as cool as
they nor
how could chrissy leave me
after everything we've been through
together chrissy
wait
isn't that the name of the found dog oh
hey
you posted about a lost dog right
i think they have her over at todd's
hardware
are you serious
thank you so much how do i know that
called right now did i see a dog at the
heart how do i know this
oh wait because that isn't about that's
about a sound dog
okay got it
cute is she okay
oh thank god
is she there now
oh awesome
yes
thank you so much
can i pick her up today
no sweat
maybe i'll get to hear her play sometime
oh it's the hot dog from the first game
cute
it's got a little shield in the sauce
still going
we've just made his day so much better
i hope we all get to see more adventures
of feynor
i can't believe he ordered that record
[ __ ]
there she is
i'm glad gabe convinced her to stay
hey i'm glad you stopped by i've only
got a sec but
[Applause]
have you talked to ethan at all
talked is maybe too strong a word i
tried
he's taking it really hard
but what you did for me this morning got
me thinking
what if ethan needs something like that
too something fun and distracting
something like a larp
like the one you and gabe were gonna
take him to yeah but designed just for
him in thane or
he'll love that yeah i'm glad you think
so i need your help though i want it to
be as good as it can be
ethan gave you one of his comics right
so
what do you think
who would the famous monster slayer have
the most fun defeating
the underworld
storm writer the undead
oh man they both look pretty cool
oh
crevious
lord of the underworld
or storm writer the undead
i mean me personally i would like lord
of the underworld
i think the the boy might like storm
right there i i don't know
i don't know maybe he like both i don't
know what what do you want what do you
guys want
i'm in i'm intrigued
what do you want me to pick should we
pick the underwear i don't know if
stormwater doesn't call too though
stormwriter looks more like um like a a
standard night kind of like evil knight
storm right there sounds cooler
nathan wants underworld
we need to sneak one more vote and then
you'll be the deciding one no no
pressure
the art looks cooler with storm right
though
the odd does that color look still in
white though
okay screw it
sorry nathan i'm going to go with jandio
let's do some right there i think the
kid will like it more
[Music]
and christopher either looks like a
worthy opponent
he gets my vote
all right then
oh i gotta get back in there there's
some stuff in my comp book be cool if
you could check it out help me make some
calls i'll see what i can do
hey haven listeners that was phone tap
with their new single elephant in the
room
we've got a sweet block of indie rock
coming down the pike but first a few
announcements oh
looks like steph wants me to do more
than just make some decisions
she wants me to play a bard
she can play with her guitar be cute
alex fill in your character
bad name
half elf that sounds nice very graceful
abilities distortion field or healing
serenade
um level one health points ten how did
you meet thanos
so we need to fill this in cube guess
i'm in
let's start with my name sponsored by
type in mining company
you can help with this name so bring
your friends bring your family halloween
hell bring your ex i'm sure it'll be
alexander alwyn
i swear like alwyn is there another
alwyn in this game or did i play a game
recently with alwyn i was playing
witcher 3 yesterday so maybe it was
there
i don't know i think i'm gonna go
oh alto obvious alto alto that's like a
music thing because she's a bard alto is
a good name for a bard yeah
ability time
distortion field sounds fun
but healing serenade could really come
in handy
uh i want to do healing serenade for
this one i think
yeah i want to do healing serenade i'm
so sorry i said tonight i'd let you
choose here but hi for anyone healing
serenade we choose the how do i meet
dana how did i meet thaynor
heroic story or a funny story
i will let you choose this one nathan
chris wanted healing too
oh i think alwyn is in the comic
gabriel you're so right that's why we
that's why we heard alwyn because he was
writing his little comic and then he saw
alwyn at the end
ah it's fine
oh no i wish i wish i'd
thought more and chosen alwyn now but oh
well
got to be heroic okay let's go with
heroic
it was a dark and stormy night
this larp thing just might work
damn it
can i can i re-do
i and i will make a great team i want to
change the name please
no sweet it was a dark and stormy night
but that didn't stop the townsfolk from
gathering to make merry and the
amphitheater under the roof and with
beers aplenty none noticed the beast
lurking in the darkness they didn't
stand a chance the beast attacked
killing all of its path i fought bravely
but at last i am a singer not a fighter
just as my strength failed a brave
warrior appeared thanor the monster
slayer together we fought off the beast
and saved the town
nice
alpha i do read the chat i am
it's lag it's like five seconds away i
still need to check the flower shop for
mac
yeah i chose heroic for nathan that was
his choice islam
nathan is nsg productions
if you're all confused about what i'm
talking about
um
i think ethan's gonna love it nice
so
the last place that we have to go to
is
the
flower shop
i don't get it
do people just not want ice cream
anymore
i looked over the budget if we only open
three days a week we'll be able to
scrape by
is that it
are we always just going to scrape by
things we'll get back to keep up a brave
face for angela she loves our store so
much he must be exhausted
oh i was right huh how do those words
taste
not
like
we're losing our business
but it's like
everything's a joke to him she must feel
so alone
hope they figure it out yeah
communication should push the rum raisin
harder it's surprisingly addictive
you
haven't been putting actual wrong
oh sorry
still haven't found mac
jed suggested i checked the flower shop
yeah i know maybe i can go in the
background and surprise him boom
wait there was a dog around here
somewhere where's the dog
the dog that i compare because we saw
its little foot of prince
oh that was the
bridge that we started on the beginning
of the game
okay let's just go into the flower shop
eleanor
sorry
no need to apologize
how are you dear
oh she's such a happy lady i'm um i
can't be
adjusting i'm okay
i'm adjusting i'm adjusting
still just trying to adjust i think i i
come across so like depressed give
yourself some time i'm fine i'm fine
change is always hard
it's good to be honest
uh is mac here
uh he was helping me not too long ago i
think he just left we can't have gotten
too far
got it
thanks
no hope
hmm
she looks terrified
i can't leave her like this
would you like a gnome
i can't use my power on her for some
reason
okay is there anything around the store
that might
be triggering oh wait yeah that was
strange okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
time to figure out why she's afraid
[Music]
the doctor said i had more time
but
everything is becoming
so
out of order
[Music]
i feel
broken
got like dementia or something
that's horrible
if they know about my conditioning
so this is when you're inside someone
else's head basically
being able to see things the way that
they would so that you can understand
more
i miss something
[Music]
oh yeah
never been in here before
before riley riley finds out
she can't
find out
[Music]
thank you dear
i'll get started on it right away
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah alzheimer's yeah
[Music]
it's quite cool it's all represented
it's not just that she forgot what she
was doing
she's afraid she's forgetting
everything
but how can i help her
let's try forget what you were working
on
you could say i'm having a bit of a
senior moment
well maybe i can help
yeah she can show she's not alone
um
we chose the steps
seems like you have a lot going on today
[Music]
i could help you retrace your steps oh
i don't wanna keep you
[Music]
hey
i
i want to help
[Music]
okay
okay what would eleanor have done first
well i mean first
i'm sure she would have used the phone
right
do you think she would have taken an
order
did you maybe call someone
i can't say for sure
did anything happen with riley
you don't have to do this
i'll be all right on my own
hey
i'm not going anywhere
did you trim these flowers today
i
don't remember
the cash register is broken
you must have flipped the sign to open
that's true of course i want to be the
first thing i always flip it first thing
when i come in
and then i open my mail
something must have distracted me
better
we can do this
yes jan that's why i like playing these
games as well they
they do touch on really
serious mental health topics
in usually very delicate ways which is
nice
okay so
she would have
done
the
open the door
well if she was getting distracted then
that probably would have been the phone
could a phone call distracted you
[Music]
yes
i got a call first thing in the morning
but i can't think who it was did you
write it down maybe we can find
something to remind you
was it riley
could it have been riley who called
i think that's right
she called to tell me about a new order
oh
goodness what was the order for
hmm
we're getting there
we're getting there
let's have a look at the plants the
plants the flowers
fresh order
this must be what riley came in for
i think that order might have been for
these lilies
of course
riley helped me pick them out before she
left
now we just have to figure out who
ordered them
oh they're not dead she just saw them as
dead
right or am i going crazy
no i think she just saw them as dead
the check for the lilies would be in
here right
that could tell us who bought them
should
[Music]
yes gabriel psychonauts 2 is great at
that mr jedidiah luken it's more like
kid-friendly and
faster paced and fun
this is more like chilled out calm
relaxing
in depth
that's a that's expensive
looks like the lilies are for jet
that's right
riley dropped off an order for jed
i knew you'd figure it out
i couldn't have done it without you
seriously alex
you're a godsend
oh
jed must be hosting some event
i wonder why he wants lilies though
they're traditionally for funerals
god crap she doesn't remember she
doesn't remember bad oh no
[Music]
i mean
oh no
i hate this i obviously tell her about
gabe but i don't know whether it should
come from me
should we tell her
i feel bad just acting like you know
but
abe wants to spare her the pain because
she's gonna find out eventually anyway
because she can't just go around a tiny
little village and not know
like someone's gonna tell her
um
and it could get her into some really
awkward situations but it's like if you
tell her is she just going to forget
again or if you tell her she's going to
go oh crap i'm glad you told me and now
i don't have to look like an idiot in
front of
everyone else in the village
or is she going to be like ah i wish
someone i loved could have told me
she will definitely find out eventually
exactly
she will definitely find that eventually
go for it feels right
[Music]
i mean she's already going through a lot
of stuff on her own though
ask her yeah i'm gonna spare her the
pain oh she's gonna find out eventually
but hopefully someone that she loves can
tell her
ah but
i don't know write it on her
she could be angry if you didn't tell
her oh my god fine motion but just tell
them
okay
gosh
they were
they were for gabe's wake
gabe's wake
gabe's wake
oh no she missed oh that's so sad missed
it
alex i
i'm so sorry hey i am glad we told her
that
excuse me
oh [ __ ]
okay
that sucks
at least i told her the truth
[Music]
that poor young man
how did i forget i'm so sorry eleanor
okay
riley is officially a badass
soldering yeah
she is
i've definitely lived in uglier places
it's very pretty
wait can we go back to riley and talk to
her about
my hair now
i hope it's good news
oh that was for her
i'm just fertilizing it
jesus
oh god
they're multiplying
what do you want you want to make fun of
me too like those other jock [ __ ]
what no
you made a sick kill a robot and won a
[ __ ] contest that's
first of all we got third place and
anyway he's not a robot technically he's
oh
god way to take the bait right
oh okay so hallelujah
[ __ ] those pricks you rule and i
would
really like to see your robot
if you want to show me
yes how to get a date make a robot
i should get an emotional support dog
but like for other people cute doggy dog
dogs
okay
let's uh
i want to go and see great things have
small beginnings
or some
if we can talk to riley
eleanor said mack is nearby
i don't see him here
maybe at the bridge
[Music]
thanks for spending time with me
thanks for letting me
where's the dog
why did i do this
okay
i am gonna leave it here and then finish
the rest of episode two
next week it looks like i'm gonna be
doing
like the end of an episode and then the
beginning of one hopefully i'll get
to finish an episode
and then start from the beginning again
at the start of the stream but who cares
we're gonna keep playing anyway so
thanks so much for watching
um
that game really did
uh
just freaking
end on a
really weird note that i just did not
expect to happen
i did not expect our brother to die it's
at the end of um
the first episode
did not see that happening
so yeah definitely a twist
but i am very much enjoying it it's it's
very chilled out it's very relaxed
there's
a lot to do and explore and people to
talk to and i really like this mechanic
of being able to unlock thoughts and
memories and especially the fact that
it's based within a small tiny rural
village
you definitely do get the sense that
everyone knows each other and uh yeah
it's it's cool to explore uh an
environment like that not to mention how
freaking gorgeous it is and obviously
brilliant music as always um so yeah
very much looking forward to playing it
again next week
so
i'm gonna say goodbye to who i can see
in the chat
um goodbye
the dog was at the hardware store though
uh could i even get into the hardware
store though
where is the hardware store though
could i get into the hardware store oh
i've just gone out to the main menu yes
i can maybe i'll try and find the
hardware store
next time i don't think i'm finished
looking around yet anyway i just don't
want to trigger another cutscene because
i think the bridge is like right next to
the flower shop um
but yeah i think it's
i don't know i haven't been into a
hardware store yet i i don't know if you
can't even actually go there but
maybe we'll find out next week
so okay good night uh chris thanks for
coming
uh sydnata goodbye sendata livestream
tonight good stuff
goodbye lynya goodbye f196
goodbye and you take care of yourself
too ev goodbye frank goodbye nathan
sorry about the no puppies but maybe
next week goodbye
pirunchoff
oh hello you said hello hello and
goodbye sorry
sorry i'm leaving
um goodbye
colin williams oh
did you just make it again oh well thank
you so much for coming i'm so sorry you
always come as i'm leaving but hello
um
and goodbye to anyone who um who i
haven't seen in the chat and goodbye as
always to anyone who is watching but who
isn't in the chat i really appreciate
you being here as well so have a lovely
dear evening i will see you next
thursday at 8 30 pm bst and
uh